hey Brian oh I didn't see you there oh
you scared the heck out of me sorry I
was just busy focus trying to build this
sculpture with all these building blocks
that we have the problem is this is so
unstable and it keeps falling over and I
spend so much time trying to maintain
and build these things I know someone
who has just the same problem with
computer resources they tried Hadoop but
it fails often and is super expensive
there must be a better way some sort of
tool that builds all these things for us
and maintains it so we can spend more
time analyzing and doing the things that
we love instead of spending all of our
time building and maintaining big data
Brock you know what I have just the
thing nice
let me show you how to create a large
data proc cluster with preemptable nodes
using the Google Cloud console or just a
command line in minutes first we'll
create the cluster will give the cluster
a name then we'll pick a place to put it
we are in New York so we'll pick us
yeast next we get to choose the cluster
mode and there are three choices for
this demo we'll go with standard after
that we get to pick the shape of the
master node we'll go with two V CPUs
we'll set the primary disk to ten GB
which happens to be the minimum then we
get to customize the shape of the worker
nodes and you'll see it's really easy to
customize the shape and this was really
important for a customer of mine we'll
set the primary disc size to 10 GB again
and we're creating a really large
cluster with preemptable nodes so let's
configure the preemptable nodes next
we'll set the number of nodes to 400 and
the shape of these nodes will match the
primary worker nodes now we could create
the cluster right through this user
interface or what what we can use is the
rest command that it Auto generates or
even the g-cloud command which is also
auto-generated now because I want to
measure the time it takes to create this
cluster I have a little script that will
run using cloud shell and that will
create the cluster for us today
now as this cluster is being provisioned
we can actually track the progress
through this user interface so we could
go up and click on the clusters and
you'll see about 400 nodes being
provisioned as we speak you can click
through and go to the details look at
the VM instance list and you will see
all of these preemptable nodes getting
provisioned now a few things about using
preemptable x' in your cluster
they help you run very large clusters at
a low total cost the Machine type of
these preemptable nodes
matches the Machine type of the primary
workers now within a data proc cluster
preemptable instances are added to a
managed instance group and as you know
they can be reclaimed at any point of
time so these instances can be read back
into the cluster if and when capacity is
available also a few things to consider
about preemptable x' they're used as
processing nodes only and do not store
data by default preemptable nodes are
created with the smaller of 100 GB or
the size of the primary nodes persistent
disk and this is again used only for
local caching and is not available for
HDFS also you cannot create a data proc
cluster with preemptable only nodes at
minimum a data proc cluster will have
two primary nodes this ensures that the
cluster will never run out of workers
you can add or remove preemptable from a
cluster as needed and even set the
number of preemptable x' in a cluster to
0 50 percent or lower of the total
number of worker nodes being preemptable
is a good working ratio as you can see
the cluster is now ready for use and it
only took a couple of minutes and you
can even submit your jobs through this
user interface now thank you for showing
us that's really cool so what you're
telling me is that with a few clicks of
the mouse we can easily set up these
large clusters that build and heal
themselves also I really do love that
it's super quick to do and it doesn't
take ages to set up and build like it
did when I used to have to do this by
hand but my blocks
my poor blocks don't you have anything
out there that will build this for me
well Brian we can't build your blocks
for you but what you just saw were the
building blocks for big data analytics
that is really cool thank you so much
for watching and remember to click
subscribe and share this video and if
you're working on any cool projects
connect with us by clicking on the link
in the description below
[Music]